[Music]
so here's something from Jimmy Fallon
show from The Tonight Show he
is I guess trying to do a comedy skit
about the new covid variant oh that's
actually hilarious In fairness I suppose
it's like it's maybe not easy to think
of funny jokes about a covet variant
but you're a comedian so that's what
you're supposed to be able to do I don't
have to think of the jokes I'm not the
comedian you are instead of thinking of
jokes this is what Jimmy Fallon did
let's play this there was Alpha then
Delta then Omicron X but this late is
variant might be the best it's xbb Point
1.5 another brand of covid-19 has
arrived it's a new strain but it isn't
the same sounds more like Elon musk's
name it's X
IV 0.1.5
UB40 who sings Red Red Wine put on your
map when you're inside a facility it
could be a robot from a Star Wars
Trilogy it's xdd Point 1.5 not OMG or
MP3 or tcpy
it's
XC Point 1.5
xbv 0.15
[Applause]
. you don't feel bad for the band there
they're not into it they realize it's
not even a good like
we gotta we have to there have to be
laws there's no other way around this
there got to be laws okay they have to
be laws against being this unfunny uh
it's the criminal penalties are the only
way that I can see to really solve this
problem this is it shouldn't be legal to
be this aggressively unfunny and you
have a comedy show
my God and it's not even a good song so
I think this I don't watch any of the
late night shows but this is basically
Jimmy Fallon this is his shtick this has
always been a shtick that he does a lot
of musical stuff and uh what's the other
guy that's that's leaving a show I can't
even remember their names names anymore
uh same thing for him like that's that's
where all the cops that's where all the
late night shows are now they're just
like doing it's a musical act
and usually that's a way around trying
to be funny well we'll just do a musical
act instead okay if you're gonna go that
route I'd rather you just tell jokes
that are funny but if you're gonna go
the musical then at least make it a good
song a song that sounds passable as an
actual song that wasn't even that that
was like high school talent show level
really bad stuff but
it's all part and parcel of the problem
of uh of you know a whole profession of
Comedians and very few of them actually
know how to do comedy
moving on also I also had to had this
this is a new gender this is kind of a
breaking news I suppose there's a new
gender that has been added to the list
now
I think this is new it kind of here's
there's a problem you hear it described
and it sounds very familiar because this
is how all of the fake native genders
are described
but this is even so a new innovation
listen hello yes I thought I should
probably address this comment I identify
as gray gender which means I feel ties
to certain genders but
um
it's really hard to describe it's really
hard to Define for me it's really close
to being gender fluid I just don't
personally feel like I have strong
enough
um consistent enough like repeated
enough dysphoria to calm myself gender
fluid
and in the end I don't really care how
people perceive me hence great gender
that's its definition the thing is
sometimes I do feel dysphoria
and sometimes it's intense
so essentially I will never care what
gender of pronouns what gendered
compliments what gendered questions
um you have for me I occasionally I will
be feeling a certain set of pronouns
more pronouns do not equal gender but
for me personally they do thank you for
asking
oh yeah she doesn't I don't care how you
perceive me I'm I'm making this video
to tell you all about myself perceptions
and to tell you how you should perceive
me but I don't care how you perceive me
sometimes I feel this pronoun what the
hell does it mean to feel a pronoun how
can you feel I'm feeling a certain I'm
feeling very
we right now what does that mean okay
tell me what that means
describe a pronoun feeling of course
it's all it's all nonsense and it's all
it's not only nonsense but it's the
worst kind of nonsense in that it is
redundant nonsense it just repeats
itself over and over again and all of
the uh alternative genders and the Neo
pronouns they are they are all described
as well it's always the same video of
some person usually a woman kind of
holding her chin like she's being
thoughtful you know this is how I would
describe it sometimes I feel this way
sometimes I don't oh you're moody in
other words a okay join the club with
every other woman on the planet that's
that what you're describing is just
you're Moody you're just you have moods
actually it's not just women that have
moods I tell you men have moods too
guess what you don't need your own
pronoun for every mood you happen to
have
which doesn't make sense to begin with
it's extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here's why expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all expressvpn doesn't slow
down your user experience you can even
stream HD videos with zero buffering
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
that's maybe the best thing about it all
you got to do fire up the app tap one
button and you're connected it's not
just me saying this Business Insider The
Verge many other Tech journals right
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
entire world protect yourself with the
VPN I trust use MyLink
expressvpn.com Walsh YT today and get
three months free on a one-year package
that's exp
resvpn.com walshyt
expressvpn.com
walshyt speaking of nonsense
I guess that's the theme that's always
the theme uh here's I don't I don't know
exactly where this is from I don't think
we need a lot of uh background for this
some kind of podcast where we've got
someone here
talking about twerking and she says that
twerking look it's not just some person
shaking their butt there's something
deeper going on with the twerking she
explains here shaking is such a primal
practice of releasing trauma and somatic
blockages and emotions through our body
especially our hips our hips now we know
is where we store emotions so when you
are twerking when you're shimmying you
are literally releasing trauma leading
releasing stored emotions from your hips
when you're bending your knees you're
crouching on the floor you're connecting
to Earth you're connecting to the womb
you're restoring your energy and that's
why it's not even just an African dance
but in Middle Eastern dance in Latin
American dance salsa dance bachata every
single dance form has some form of hip
movement to it this is also why zebras
when they're running away from a lion
and they're about to get eaten and they
make it into the nick of time they shake
their bodies off release the trauma and
they come back to homeostasis so I
started to realize that as I was doing
this I was healing myself through all of
these generations of collective trauma
that now we know with epigenetics is
actually stored within our systems and I
realize that twerking shimmying
undulating shaking truly is a spiritual
practice and now I share it as much as I
can
oh that's what you're doing that's what
strippers are doing I'm sharing my
spiritual practices
that's all I got strippers are like
expressing their trauma in a certain way
that's how they end up in the strippers
pull uh this is all no no actually what
you're doing is you're just shaking your
ass that's all that's all you're doing
you're harshly shaking your ass uh and
you are it is animalistic in a certain
way you know you're like it's a it's a
it's a very primitive animalistic mating
ritual if anything
so
uh lots of uh you know I thought we
would get some psychobabble I didn't
think that we would get the Zoological
part of that
um where now we're told that um
that zebra's twerk as a coping mechanism
after being chased by the Lions don't
let the Lions know about this
you know let's make sure Lions don't
find out that that's what happens
they're chasing the zebra zebra gets
away lion says oh man I gotta go find a
different meal little does the lion know
the zebra's just over there in the
bushes twerking having a torque Fest so
just sneak up take them while they're
twerking
my God
this is where you store your emotions in
your hip
and if you get close to the ground you
release those emotions
I always I don't even when I when I
watch a video like this or I see someone
spouting absolute absolute gibberish my
frustration is is not as much with the
person who's spouting the gibberish
because I you know I'm familiar with
that like I'm I there are people out
there that just have nothing to say and
so they they spout gibberish like I get
it
I mean I don't get it I can't understand
the gibberish but but I understand that
those people exist my primary issue is
always with the person listening and
taking it seriously so the other person
in the conversation I blame them most of
all when you're sitting there and
someone is telling you that you store
your emotions in your hips and that
twerking allows you to release those
emotions into the ground
to what
so it seeps into the ground and your
emotions poison the water supply like
how does that work exactly the person's
sitting there and say yeah that makes
sense I could totally see that yeah
this is a nice excuse though the idea
that you store your emotions somewhere
else in your body
so if you don't you know I so I don't
have a beer gut I just that's where I
store my emotions that's that's where I
store my ancestral trauma it's all right
there in the gut
all right I can't even I actually had
one more thing to play and I'm not even
gonna do it I can't do it I think we've
seen enough